hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - does
that mean that was that music always
there I seem to have cranked up the
music a bit more than I did before
and there's a lot more music and
ambiance than I previously noticed but
either way I changed around some
settings in the emulation so hopefully
there aren't gonna be any more
distortions in the game but then again
if there are I can't really control it
because it's an emulation and I I don't
really know what I'm doing when I'm
doing these emulation things I probably
should have just done it in the normal
aspect and not done it through an
emulation software but I didn't have a
copy so that's all a moot point at this
point also I know that I need to relax
my mind you know how I said I was too
smart in this game well that still
stands I still stand by that and if you
don't agree with it
how dare you oh yeah and also I learned
about this glitch you can make her kind
of kind of stutter step her way around
the town a little bit hey hey are there
any ghosts around here hey here you go
scumming I got asked a vigilant for my
sister or whatever or maybe I should
need to stay vigilant up my sister you
know what we what we did was we got the
key whoa I've been in there I don't
think he can go up there anyway either
way no anyway we got the key that can
unlock the door to my sister at least
that's what I'm assuming it can do which
means I need to go back into the house
and I need to free her from her
entrapment not that I necessarily want
to but hey that's what the game wants me
to do and then I need to discover why
she's possessing all this thing it's
going horribly wrong and this village
wants to make a sacrifices to the
grapevine in the ground somewhere I
don't necessarily know if it actually
was the well or if I'm just going crazy
but that's always a possibility because
whenever I play these horror games it
seems that I'm either trapped in a
situation where everyone else is going
crazy or I'm going crazy and just think
everyone else is going crazy either way
it's gonna be lots of fun for the whole
family
get ready for an adventure everybody I'm
so ready
ok back into this old place and I know I
said this whoa whoa whoa hey whoa wait
whoa
you're an actual enemy oh I thought okay
I thought that you weren't an enemy I
thought you were actually like just
there to harass me okay hang on
so what you guys told me is that I do
need to wait hey what the hell for the
hell are you oh you're from the lake are
you that lady that was moaning in my ear
well did I mention how I didn't
appreciate that very much hey thanks Mel
did she really take all that much help
off me damn alright whatever I wasn't
ready for that
actually let me load up with a bit more
powerful film here because I seem to
have a good bit of it I'm gonna use it
now you guys reminded me that in order
to get the combo shots where are you
where are you
we're yet where is she she's oh oh there
you are oh why are you floating all the
way over there I'm coming for you I need
to wait for the red light to flash if I
want to get combos that is weird
back oh god dammit I I panic like that
it's it gets it that's a good shot it's
a good shot but if I want the fatal
frame shot I gotta wait until the red
light hits it because if I don't then I
won't be able to get a combo and then
I'm just gonna have to whoa whoa whoa
whoa she's old
that wasn't a fatal frame okay so no I
sometimes panic and I'm just like well I
need to shoot her anyway
just cuz otherwise she's gonna kill okay
they're here right so I'm gonna wait
this time I'm gonna wait I got the power
we got the power I could get it but I'm
gonna
wait gonna wait come on gimme oh come on
mah god oh god the controls are wonky
where you were yet they're here okay I
didn't see any like opportunity maybe I
just need to tow she's diving
why are you diving into the lake little
girl where'd you go where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go where are
you oh where are you oh where are you oh
oh oh god that was my moment that was
like no time to react oh no Lisa is it
usually how these engagement goes ooh
hey I come to you what are you doing oh
hey hey hey how are you doing
you look cool sabi I've been hearing so
much about are you cusan nabe why can't
I get a shot of you what are you okay oh
okay ah
y'all got damnit that wasn't good enough
okay she does like this I I have to like
understand the pattern of the ghost
before I'm actually able to do anything
to them they like do a diving swoop and
when I see your face that's probably
when the fatal frame shot is no she's
still over here whoa whoa whoa
okay I'm wasting light okay got you a
power boost there we go okay that
finished up okay it hurts does it well
it hurts when you annoy me and poke me
with your ectoplasmic goop I don't much
a pretty face thank you goodbye goodbye
forever did you leave me any goodies
besides some pictures that'll church
forever one day I'll show my grandkids
all of the pictures of the ghosts that I
took here oh and this is one she only
almost took my soul oh this is when I
completely lost my mind and killed
everyone in the village accidentally
totally a misunderstanding this when I
cast my sister back into the pit of hell
at the bottom of the lake in the well in
the whatever the thing is I don't even
know I'm assuming that part of the
sacrifice because part of the sacrifice
did say that one of the sisters needed
to go through the portal hell so I'm
only assuming that I'm gonna have some
sort of a choice at the end it's game
where it's either gonna be me or her
it's not gonna be me give me that one
it's absolutely certain okay so there
was a side entrance that I came out of
the sister was held up over here I
believe yeah the cell over there so if I
just take the side door I guess I could
just go this long way through the front
door if the front door is unlocked now
let's just try that first might as well
try the front door no reason not to
oh no it's held shut by mysterious force
that is exactly a reason not to marry
what else do you have
where was that side door oh there it is
okay super secret side door that no one
knows about at all and for some reason
the selkie was kept all the way in
another house the flashlight went out oh
I forgot about that I don't know the
comfort in my light oh yeah this leads
to wrong forgot about the music you know
in a lot of ways like going down to
these dark cellars it reminds me almost
exactly of when I first started playing
amnesia because it's like a whoa
hello who's there who are you well come
on give me your fatal frame give me your
fatal frame give you a fatal frame give
me I want to combo it up combo it's so
good oh this to you combo the whole tier
you'll be giving it god damn it that
wasn't even any Oh God really
whoa whoa oh there we go and I'm gonna
combo and combo
I missed it ah Oh Howie Howie oh that's
right when their life I forgot that when
they get shot they flail around like a
bunch of deuces
no no no no no god this is gonna be
tough
do these [ __ ] okay so getting combos
on these guys might actually be a lot
harder than I thought because if they do
flail around then if I'm not like whoa
that's not what I wanted at all run a
little farther away because god he's
quick he's quick yeah I'm gonna get you
show me show me show me show me that
pretty side up until I get you I think I
got you okay that's something at least
and now run away run away he's gonna
flail you got a flail he's gonna flail
oh that guy's so quick oh where am I
going oh [ __ ] we're okay there give me
give me a good shot okay that's good
enough I'm out here Oh screw you
Oh screw you can I get by Oh let me
squeeze by okay no yeah you guys suck
out some of my energy how dare you suck
out the energy of me don't you know that
I'm something or someone or something to
someone
everybody's something to somebody here
we go I just need to get some help back
this is this really hard like this a lot
harder than I thought it'd be like
getting these bright shots right when
you need them
without
finish you off oh oh I think I got you
it like you're like flickers it flickers
and I wish it didn't flicker like that
because I want to know that I can get
the shot exactly what I needed
you're next you're next up come on come
on give me give me give me give me
you probably just finish you off like
this but I want to get sim oh we go
crazy well where is it
where is he oh did I get him both oh
okay they don't have a lot of health but
they're a little problematic okay I got
it
uh-huh this is really stressful
sometimes when I'm actually trying to do
like as good as I can it's quite
stressful oh man I'm getting a little
better
at least I understand what I need to do
it's this about getting those fatal
frames they're so finicky on them it's
all about understanding the animation
it's like well you know what I played um
like uh what's go Devil May Cry or any
type of game like that all about getting
like the right combos at the right time
sir I'm not very good at fighting games
I'm not good at timing that sort of
stuff I mean I am if I really really
practice at it but I didn't grow up on
those types of games so I wasn't about
all that stuff I guess it's a principle
that I need to know okay is this where
she is
oh she's not there anymore you can't see
my Oh from the window maybe she's in the
back of the self oh yeah
oh I'm sure oh I'm sure that's it
that's a great idea and the key snapped
in half
my you
my she's not here is he
my oh this is a good idea oh this is a
very good idea oh yeah
oh I'm sure this is great yeah thank you
my use note says run and are you gonna
leave me again in Japanese on the wall
old piece of paper
Itsuki I'm so sorry I want to see you
and tell you how sorry I am
I'm sorry about cheeto say - I don't
know who - Tosa is okay wait here boy no
photo I know I was talking to him why do
I need to know about that now
yeah
so drawing an almost exact parallel to
what happened before that's great
Oh another one oh this is this is in the
mind of my you hey my you
oh yes follow the butterflies that's a
good idea how did you get out of the
cell I went to fetch the key I went a
long way to try to do this for you you
ungrateful sister you how dare you I
mean I try and I try I'm emotionally
strapped try to do the things for you
but you're asking me are you asking me
not to leave you behind it in the end
you left me behind but it's having
trouble trusting again okay anyway on
the table lit by okay
Japanese Girl doll oh yeah I forgot
about the doll why is there a doll under
there
it's a life-size doll is it okay so I've
already been through here I don't think
there would be anything else unless my
you got her mind lost in the books oh
he's a bookworm that Mayu
mmm-hmm okay so I guess I need to go the
way that my you went great I did all of
that for nothing
maybe I okay great then I did all of
great oh did I go that way no I don't
think I don't think I went that way I
went this way because this way leads to
the basement who's gonna help me got
that camera angle is really weird I
think the camera has a mind of its own
like the camera itself is another ghost
with another camera just trying to
tricks me yell Trixie Trixie be the way
I just need to follow the clues the
cutscene clearly said that by you in
another way follow in some more
butterflies which is probably not a good
thing but I need to just follow along
because that's what the game wants me to
do if I overthink it with my big brain
I'm just gonna get myself lost
I mean a lot of ways this game kind of
place itself except for the combat
aspect of it and even then I'm not the
best at it and I wish I was better I may
I'll be able to get better this game
goes on but setting up those combos is
something that's actually pretty
difficult for me and someone who's
actually mentioning in the comments that
the emulator is actually playing tricks
on me like it's not supposed to be that
finicky like I don't know what that's
all about maybe it is maybe it isn't but
like if it is just the emulator that's
making it more difficult than it should
be then hey that's a relief for me but
I'm gonna go on the assumption that I'm
just bad and I'm not that an expert at
this just yet
but I will be alright speaking of that I
probably need to upgrade my camera a
little bit um
someone said upgrade sensitivity I will
do that because that is what oh no sorry
function bara sensitivity BAM
and also I need to put an orb into if
I'm using blast oh I already did get in
blast okay so I don't need that maybe
maybe if I use the stun powerup maybe if
I use a slug if I use the slow powerup
more than I would have more of an
opportunity to get those fatal frames
I'm guessing so yeah I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go with slow for now I'm gonna go
slow for now just because if I use slow
and I can probably set up combos better
it'll be better than just hitting hard
with a blast which requires two
power-ups anyway so that's what I'll do
this is my strategy for the moment I
don't know if it's right I don't know at
all I'm just going off my basic
assumptions in this game because at the
end of the day I am slaved of gain and
and it's whim I am subject to it this is
getting oddly sexual but not that I
meant it to be that way everybody get
your minds out of gutter hey I think in
this whole game in the soul play through
everyone's mind has been permanently
stuck in the gutter for no apparent
reason there should be no reason that is
that way but there we go
okay when I stall for time my mind
wanders quite a bit okay
so there's where the butterflies went
early yeah this was yeah no okay this is
different
Oh cutscene my you are you know my you
stop being weird for once in your life
Oh No look I bye huh well that was weird
also someone noticed that uh wait can I
take a picture of that
oh no correct lis above me yeah I got it
yeah I don't worry about you I got it
clear shot as everyone could see the
ghosts right here we heard it's
ectoplasmic calls on our radio we reason
okay so I know how to get up there it
was not through that door it was through
a door over here wasn't it was it over
here which way wasn't it was it was
through here wasn't it
I remember I remember I went this way
because I went the wrong way I went in
this house before I was supposed to go
on the map would show where the entrance
was yeah oh he's right over there
so I was almost there yeah because I
went in this house before I needed to
wait why can't I go in now wait I
thought I could go in here before
goodnight wait am I am I totally
mistaken here uh
I'm uh I think I'm totally mistaken it
might have been it must have been that
one yeah I must have been that nevermind
yeah it must have been that one it must
have been that one but I don't remember
going through that door to get in there
I remember going through cuz I remember
going up on that walkway I was able to
go up on that walkway but not from this
door here this door was locked
should I get up there oh I did go
through here oh I'm a dingus nevermind
ignore me I'm dumb my brain once again
working way too hard
wait harder than it should have you know
what I mean okay so from here no I
wasn't here I went off yeah that's right
okay up the stairs through here and then
take a left at the top of the stairs and
I was able to go through the pathway cuz
I've already explored this house before
I actually needed to
they came through here ah ok so they
went through here didn't my you go
through I have to find some other way in
what a bunch of bull berry what about
you baloney
who's there whoa who's it hey whoa hey
whoa hey well you slow down slow down
there yeah you slope Oh No
you're caught in slow motion I can get
that weary what why why why why sobbing
um yeah Dom Mia Mia and me what what is
this what you were just whoa whoa hey
hey whoa Fatal Frame gotcha oh no fatal
frame
Oh No oh I thought I could get another
one there ah it was almost there it's
almost there
are you doing with your broken neck
there lady slow you again that's all I'm
gonna do slow you down okay I think
that's just like okay I think that just
like delayed it I need to slow her at
the right point where she's coming up on
me like this and then slow her there
wait for the fatal prey right there okay
fatal frame right there
Laster BAM it again got it no shot give
me another one I want another one
another wait am I on I'm only a type 14
film where'd you go I think she went
back into the area
hey I'm a ghost
Hey
wait for it wait for it wait for it wait
for it wait for it wait for it wait for
it wait for it wait for it you're
getting really close on you there you go
okay pause there oh yeah that's a good
shot so weird Oh dog she's gonna do her
I gotta wait for her to get close enough
to do her mouthy thing and then I need
to shoot her in the double shot combo
right there okay
oh no you're about to attack oh I gotcha
knows it I was a fan of him and then
another one
give me another give me another give me
another oh that was it yeah yeah I
gotcha I did it expertly handled
everyone applaud that was actually good
I did it right I did I did it I did god
I did exactly what I was supposed to do
in the ex ex profession I'm so locked
okay so I need to find another way in
but this ghost didn't have a key did she
uh ectoplasmic gay huh it's all goopy
and sticky
yeah why did I pick this up uh okay so I
need to find another way in so as far as
I know there was nothing in here whoa
hey family I don't see a thing man in
study yes this is man in study I'm an
expert ghost hunter you can see it
clearly very clearly the earth´s must be
underground very good very good man in
study how much man years did you study
and that man in study study did you do
to get that conclusion
folklorist okay the key are you house
and the Tachibana house are linked by a
connecting corridor and called the twin
houses the twin shrine maiden's will
stay there before the ceremony and
apparently cleanse there too
during this cleansing they're not
allowed to go outside but they may pass
freely between the houses the bridge on
the second floor of the Tachibana house
is called the heaven bridge and the
bridge in the basement of the kuru house
is called the earth bridge the earth
bridge also connects a passageway below
ah so there's a bridge underground the
passageway is a natural cave under the
village at its deepest point lies a
forbidden place only certain class of
veiled priests and people make all the
mourners Manor it seems that the gate to
hell is there and the forbidden ritual
is actually performed underground okay
so the well was not the gate
well if you have to get to the gate tail
o laz alight a well alright then let's
see what this crazed man has to say with
his laser lights
knowing one of the Queen's okay but why
why do that why need do that I mean
obviously this whole town has gone to
hell but I don't know if it's gone to
hell because of what you've done or what
you haven't done or maybe this is a
punishment because you've done things
that you didn't need to do I don't know
okay but either way I need to find a way
to go underground now how do I go
underground that is a good question
door seems to be locked so my only guess
is there's got to be some sort of a
secret passage down here but maybe I
need to speak with the white-haired kid
again before I can actually do that
cuz the upper the heaven gate corridor
thing is locked but maybe there's like a
trick wall or something or maybe there's
a secret I don't know
is there anything nope what was it the
space between the staircase pieces of
wall and wood okay not that so there's
got to be like maybe through here I
don't remember I'm just a scared little
girl okay oh then no this is where the
film predictor but I got another real
that's right I remember I have a second
real film real seven okay bloob again
sorry I'm standing in the way my big fat
butt is blocking the path a door doors
okay
oh hi okay I thought that was a ghost I
was worried for a second there okay so
that was that showing me a secret
opening that I could get through somehow
I know there was a door back here but
that was in the page it seems to be
locked that probably goes down to the
other area heavy cloth sways in the wind
why not look behind that cloth because I
got a bad feeling about what's behind
that cloth all right fine
don't do that don't do what I say don't
look behind the cloth
okay so there's some secret door
somewhere I don't know if it's up here
or not but that's my one clue that I've
gotten so far there's some form of a
door that a kid opened it looked like a
kid anyway opened and went through let
me just give the upstairs one more look
before I actually go around as far as I
know I got really nothing else to go on
because I know the entrance to the other
house is locked or at least it was the
last time I checked it may not be now
but hey you never know these things no
don't don't flip around you dingus
donger hey sassy lady if I don't keep
her in line yeah that sounded incredibly
sexist if I don't smack her around a
little bit do you know me ha ha ha
that's what I do every day
please don't misquote me on this this is
in a contextual where I'm being
sarcastic
I'm gonna shut up now never mind uh
let's just move on with the game find an
underground tunnel or something hurt I
don't know oh god oh no
come please gonna be so mad at me
alright moving on I'm gonna check the
other door at least go outside because
if I head outside there might be another
clue coming my way
early say because this game has been
good about telling me what I'm supposed
to do if I'm totally lost but I I'm
assuming that might be all the direction
that I'm gonna get because III think I
found that film real like way back when
did I find the film you did I find that
in the Osaka House I might have okay uh
tried forcing the door up and but it
didn't work so the only other way that I
could go would be okay that's thoroughly
blocked off um if I go into the know
that CEO sock house the Kurosawa Lowe
Kurosawa no way no way zoom out again
how do i zoom out again where am i what
how do i zoom out again what did I do to
zoom out uh uh damn it god damn it I can
ruin everything
okay so Ariel um okay so if I go into
the the Kiryu house but this wasn't it
there was nothing else to do besides go
on the corridor but if the kuru house
has anything else no no damn it the only
thing I could possibly check is that
other door over there because I've
already been over here no no okay all
right it said about the white-haired kid
I'm gonna go back to the white-haired
kid and I'm gonna ask him if he knows
anything else because that was the other
clue that I got there was a mention of
the white-haired kid when the twins got
split up the direct parallel in the
vision that I had also included him so
he might have some other clue for me
that's the only assumption that I have
right now so that's all I'm gonna go on
alright
that weird broken neck ghost wasn't
gonna keep flapping her gums at me maybe
she could have told me what I was
supposed to do and why she was pursuing
my you how dare she
that's my sister only I get to pursue
her and yell at her for all the bad
things that she's doing it heck maybe
she's not even alive cuz there's a
direct parallel of her falling down him
and Mayu falling down in the ghost in
the past sigh a falling down so like
maybe that's all together like I don't
know could be also I've never actually
been in this house where the boys kept
it away hopefully find some answers soon
hey can we still save her maybe those a
little less distorted than you did
before
sy is gone she might have gone to my
house my house will be locked for the
purification ceremony you'll have to go
through the qu house use the bridge that
connects the twin houses I don't want
the same thing to happen to you as did
to me
what happened to you please run away are
you dead are you saying you're dead and
you got Myrtle iced by all the people
what hello okay how does that help me
well okay but oh you get you but you
said you said unlocked it oh hey okay
nevermind sorry is my phone going off
the cure you house mechanism get
underground sighs should be there when
you get to the tachi Bonnie house yeah
you have to hurry or you won't make it
go now the reason I am imprisoned here
is because I sinned with these hands
with these hands wait though with with I
sinned with these hands ah
and then he they cut him off that's what
I was trying to get at never mind it was
an elaborate joke I know went over many
of your heads because it was just too
intelligent for you to comprehend I know
I'm a master joke Smith I can crank him
out like nobody's business and pranks
and illusions my hands weren't really
cut off in actuality they were actually
still under there but I just tucked them
in my sleeves I know that many of you
were fooled and worried that I lost my
hands but here they are intact I am okay
alright moving on now okay so I need to
unlock some sort of mechanism to get to
the underground access I don't know why
I needed to talk to him twice to be able
to get that information but okay and he
told me I needed to hurry to get someone
so the curie awarded a TV host was where
I was I think at least I'm under the
assumption that's where I was and if I
need to go somewhere else it would not
because that's still locked okay so it's
got to be some mechanism in this house
that I didn't see yet unless it was
behind the curtain
that I'm not gonna open until I talked
to that kid and suddenly I'm like oh
this mechanism it might be nothing babe
you never mind
either way it's rather silly that I need
to follow this explicit trail of
breadcrumbs to get exactly where I need
to go but I will follow its rules
because I'm a good little boy I guess
I'm a little girl in here but hey I
didn't tell you to play I ain't tell you
know you I'm taking me booze gimme nope
I said no and oh so that door seems to
be locked and there's something heavy
cloth swaying in the wind that I can't
get through it's so heavy
I just can't possibly walk through it
okay so there's nothing there okay so
that's weird because the kid is telling
me that there's a message I am in the
kurios right yeah I'm in the Kiryu house
or however you pronounce that whatever
so that means there's got to be a
mechanism in here to be unlocked nothing
in here that I could use I do that go
now or I won't make it oh it's a trick
see trick it's a trick see trick there's
a mechanism to get unground
to be unlocked was it over here there
was another no other door besides this
one up here what appears to be locked
maybe there was a sliding door up here
oh okay oh I know idea how was I
supposed to know this I just turned the
corner over here I was wandering around
for a while I was going very back and
forth on this but oh my goodness
holy crap I didn't know I needed to turn
this corner a different place shows in
the photo okay that's a well of some
sort looks like a well somewhere okay so
am I supposed to go back to the well and
do something about that what is that
like oh man how was I supposed to know
okay so I'm assuming I need to go back
to the well but I no idea how was I
supposed to know okay so that's locked
and I'm just under the assumption that I
need to go to the well the only well
then they know if it's only in one place
so yes I guess I need to go there I was
wandering around for a while okay so
apparently this is not the well that was
in question because nothing is happening
while I'm here I don't know if there's
another well in another building
somewhere but I can only explore more
maybe in the Osaka house again but
that's the only other house that I can
actually go in at the point where I am
now of beingness that I am do this at I
do okay more wandering you're RB okay so
definitely not that house a lot of these
old games well I'm not that this game is
particularly old but a lot of his games
that are adventure style and horror
exploration had a lot to do with going
back and forth between the clues that
you were piecing together it was a part
of the mystery and that kind of led to
the game and I'm not saying it's a bad
thing but a little more direction would
be nice because as well is great and all
but I have no idea what that leads to
the only well that I knew of was not
what he was talking about so it's
talking about a well that I don't know
in a house that is a mystery because
there's no well in the COTS EU house and
I don't remember there being a well in
the Osaka House but I'm gonna go back
and check just in case I overlooked one
looking at this photo and there's not a
lot to go on here but looking at this
photo
it might also not be inside house
because it looks like it's inside a wall
or something here and there's just
wooden planks it's all decrepid but it
also
looks like it might be in a courtyard
because that might be grass off to the
left side of it so I'm trying to do the
best I can but the only courtyards that
I know every there in the Osaka house
which I'm about to check right now I'm
in the house right now or back in the
big house where my U is being kept
originally I'll let you know when I find
progress
it was also another place up this
pathway and I've been in every house now
and I've looked everywhere and I can't
find where this frickin well that it
wants me to find is but I do remember
coming up here before when I wasn't
supposed to so I'm gonna go up here
again see if there's something somewhere
that I need this is insanity I've been
wandering around for 20 minutes I don't
know if the answer is staring at me in
the face and I really know I really hope
that when I finally find it I'm gonna be
like oh I should have known I'm a dingus
but I'm really racking my brain here I'm
really trying like I'm trying to figure
this out like really legitimately trying
to like pieces together like okay wants
me to find a well where am I gonna find
a well I've checked everywhere I've been
for everyone that would know I would
have find a well I looked at the picture
really closely I kind of piece together
that like in the environment that it's
in like what it's doing words doing it
but no I've not been able to find a ding
dong damn thing there's like no other
place that I could go into that would
lead to me being
oh my god right there
holy [ __ ] look the [ __ ] are you kidding
me well that's really convenient that
the picture there would show the wealth
that was like if you didn't see in the
top right corner of where it was where I
I don't know where my webcam is in this
but it might be right where I am
holy crap is it was it that obvious and
I just didn't know it what I detected
some spiritual energy around here hand
is gonna blow my mind oh man
do you guys it may not have been that
long but to me oh are you kidding me
no way when I walked by here why didn't
I find the blue glow oh my god I didn't
go back here oh I didn't go back here I
didn't go see the kid again because I
thought I got all the clues from this
area I never went back here again I
looked everywhere but here I've never
seen that I've never seen that I have
never seen that oh man have I seen that
I think I have seen that but it never
registered to me that I knew that a well
was here holy crap I was right it was by
oh this what threw me was by a wall and
by a collapsed door with wood on it but
there was grass there I have no idea
where that could be oh my goodness
like I know that I should have been able
to piece that together but in my mind
that place never even existed and I had
no reason to go back there because I'd
already cleared that in my mind I
checked every room every room every
other room that could possibly be in
this game but that place because I
didn't think I need to go back there
holy crap I'm legitimately upset at that
I'm upset at myself and I'm upset of the
game for not like oh man that I know I
know that was really obvious and it was
close by and him's near to where it was
supposed to be but why did I need to do
that
why did I need to do that this doors
probably open now right does all point
that right oh man oh wow oh wow I I am
like wow chapter six holy crap that was
like the most simple task that I could
have possibly had in any capacity where
is he what are we looking at here where
are we doing but I just I couldn't do it
why couldn't I do it days doll okay then
alright oh man I am upset at myself and
I'm slightly upset at the game and I
think I have a right to be upset at the
game for that like I wasn't planning on
it although I am a little upset but I
would I was not old Oh what what do you
mean
tabi good back gotcha fleeing dog you're
not dolls
you better not be dolls I wasn't
listening to my radio
thanks for the herbal meds hanging dolls
okay this got really freaky really
quickly all my upsetness is gone now
okay why am i following them why is that
something that I want to do right now
hey hey hey guess what vanishing twin
thanks radio for acting up when I didn't
need to - okay so I just came from the
back way this door right here seems to
be locked good good for me glad I did
that
oh is this a room where I saw in the
movie maybe the whole room is warped I
think this is the film the the area that
I saw in the movie whose excuse me why P
Rio and a bit goddamn I can't control
anything also it's getting it I've been
playing this so long that I haven't been
able to turn on the air conditioning in
it's getting really hot in here I'm
starting to sweat profusely through mice
my jacket which I didn't want to do I've
been playing for about an hour and a
half now just wandering that's how long
I've been wandering just so you know
okay so let me just find this in all end
this episode as quick as I can because I
have no idea how long the actual episode
is gonna be after I cut out the parts
whereas this wandering like a doof why
kill why kill why kill why kill why kill
why kill why kill Michael Michael
Michael okay thanks for that diary very
good putting down of your thoughts into
readable understandable things
okay herbal medicine I'll probably need
that because when I find this ghost I'm
not gonna fare too well up against it I
think oh okay so is this where you went
I don't like you oh okay this is another
safe point
anything all right you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna end the episode here
because I really don't know how long it
might be overtime but I've been playing
for a while now so I think I deserved a
little bit of a break to go sweat myself
to death but either way thank you all so
much for watching thank you for putting
up with me wandering or lying round like
a doof I know that should have been
obvious I'm kicking myself in that for
not checking back in the same place but
again I didn't have a reason to I
already cleared in my mind so thank you
all again so much for watching look
forward to the next episode coming at
you real soon and as always I will see
you in the next video or I'm wrong
they're just everywhere okay here's the
bridge wait no did I cross this bridge
wait is this the same bridge wait a
minute I was going on then it's uh uh
locked on target
I'm gonna hurt a hip